- Rawr The Dinosawr, "Is it a good idea
"to remove bullets lodged in your arm?"
(mid tempo dance music)
Hey, I think you're here
'cause you wanna know what happens to gum.
And I'm gonna answer that question
along with a bunch of others.
I'm responding to comments.
That's what we do on this channel,
we talk all things health
while having a good time.
But this is evidence based fun.
Let's do it. (vocalizing)
I'm gonna go ahead and assume
that what you're talking about
is an old bullet, like
something that's been lodged
inside your body for
a long period of time.
Not all bullets have to be removed.
Some, if they're not causing a problem,
you can do more harm than
good by removing them
and going in operatively.
Some need to be removed right away.
And some can be problematic
'cause they could be
a source of infection.
So it really depends on when
it happened, how it happened,
the area where they are,
what your anatomy's like.
But what I could say very confidently
is you shouldn't remove
bullets lodged in your arm!
Let a doctor do it, let them
decide if it's warranted
or even safe to do so.
Jillian Arthur, "Do
patients get ticklish?"
Oh yeah they do. (laughing)
I mean my pediatric kids especially.
Like when I'm pressing on their belly,
if I want to check for appendicitis
or whatever I'm checking in their belly
and I'm pressing, and they're laughing,
and they're not in any
pain, I already know
that it's very unlikely
to be an acute abdomen.
So I like when my patients
laugh and are ticklish
'cause then I know nothing
serious is going on.
"Can taking large doses
of Benadryl, 15 daily!
"For sleep cause long lasting damage?"
Yes, do not take 15
Benadryl at night for sleep.
Seriously, that's asking for trouble.
Benadryl is not a benign medication.
It truly has side-effects.
If you're needing 15 Benadryls to sleep,
that's a sign that something's not right
going on inside your body,
and you should be evaluated
properly by a doctor.
Yesthepotatoislookingatyou.
First of all, dope user name.
"How can one decrease
their libido? (laughing)
"Asking for a friend."
Decrease their libido?
Every question I've ever
been posed by a patient
has always been to increase their libido.
If you're asking to decrease your libido,
perhaps there's something
going on medically
that should be evaluated.
There's rare conditions that can cause you
to have an overly increased libido.
If you're really asking for a friend,
tell them to go see their doctor.
Ali Cato, "Why do my ears hurt
"after I wear my headphones
for a couple of hours."
If you're talking about earbuds,
I have the same problem.
I have the Apple AirPods and after a while
the plastic starts putting
pressure on my tragus here.
And it really hurts after a while.
The over ear headphones
generally should be pretty comfortable
and not causing you pain,
especially superficially
on the outside of your ear.
If your inner ears hurt, that's a sign
you're listening to your music too loudly.
Generally what I recommend
is no louder than 60% of the volume
that you should be
listening on your phone.
Allan Balce, Balch, Balce?
"Do hats slash caps cause baldness?"
In very specific circumstances.
Meaning that if you're wearing
a really tight baseball cap
or some kind of skullie
where you're actually
putting traction on your hair,
that can cause a type of
baldness called traction alopecia
I think that's exactly what it's called.
Where you're actually
pulling out your hairs
from that constant pressure.
But otherwise, if you wear
a hat that's well fitted
and not overly tight,
it's not gonna make you lose your hair.
In fact, most men will incorrectly assume
that this can happen because
they like wearing hats,
they experience male-pattern baldness,
which is a hormonal issue,
has nothing to do with the hats.
And then they'll go
ahead and blame the hats.
That's an area of
correlation versus causation.
Like men wearing hats at a certain age
experiencing baldness at that same age,
they think oh look, these
two things happened together,
they must cause one another, they don't.
Sarah Darwiche, "Question for Dr Mike.
"How and when do you recommend
eating around night shifts?
"I find it hard to plan."
I do not have great advice on this
from a personal standpoint.
Because every time I was on night shift,
it was absolute mayhem in the hospital.
The thing that I tried to do
was any time I had a moment
of silence, I would go
and eat something small.
So that I always had some
kind of food at the ready
whether it was a small
salad, a protein bar,
some kind of fruits to go, something small
will keep you feeling full, energized,
as opposed to just eating one giant meal
in the middle of the
night, getting overly full,
sleepy, that's gonna make
your life complicated.
And the one thing I
would avoid at all costs,
if possible, of course,
is caffeine at night.
Especially if you're alternating
between day and night shifts.
That'll throw off your
circadian rhythm really badly.
Fluffy Toast, mm!
I would love some fluffy toast right now.
'Cause I'm Whole30, no toast for me.
"I have really sweaty hands.
"What causes it to really
sweat, and is it normal?"
If you have really sweaty hands,
that could be a condition
called palmar hyperhidrosis.
Palmar meaning the palm of your hand,
hyper meaning more of, hidrosis, sweating.
This isn't that of an unusual condition,
but it causes a lot of distress to people
'cause when you're shaking
peoples' hands, interacting,
it's obviously very uncomfortable.
Treatments for this
usually are antiperspirant,
like the thing we use under our arms,
but here to plug those sweat glands.
The glands that are found here
are mostly eccrine sweat glands.
Which start sweating not to
thermoregulate your body,
to cool you off, but really
as a result of nervousness.
You have this sympathetic nervous system
which is your fight or flight
response nervous system.
That's what happens when you see a lion,
when you're about to give a speech,
when you're arguing with your partner.
That's why your hands sweat.
As a result, those sweat glands
start releasing that fluid.
Now, when you put antiperspirant on,
you essentially block those ducts,
no fluid gets released, you sweat less.
Sometimes they don't work.
You can use clinical strength products.
If that fails, there's
always Botox injections.
Yeah, you could actually inject Botox
into the sweat glands of your palm
to reduce that sweating.
It works really well.
I've had some doctors talk to me about it
'cause I have underarm
sweating that's pretty bad.
And I might be doing that in the future.
In fact, if you want me to
make a Botox sweating video
injection into me, God I
couldn't phrase it any worse,
leave it down below in the comments.
I want to make videos at least a series
of different medical procedures
being performed on me.
If you're game, hit me in the comments.
Jude Bratton "What eyesight
does require glasses?"
I think you mean like
what should my eyesight be
that I would need glasses?
Well, glasses are important.
First of all, I wear them.
They could help with issues
like farsightedness, nearsightedness.
The ideal vision that
many professions require
is 20/20 vision which means
that you can see an eye chart
from 20 feet away as well as
a person with normal vision
can see from 20 feet away.
If you have 20/30 vision,
that means you can see
from 20 feet what they
can see from 30 feet away.
Meaning someone with normal vision
can see better than you.
So 20/30 is worse than 20/20.
There's no rules for this.
If you have 20/30 vision, 20/40 vision,
you may have that in
one eye, in both eyes.
You need to have a conversation
with your optometrist
or ophthalmologist.
Some cases where you need
perfect vision for your job,
it's important to correct
your vision early on.
In some other instances
where it's not a big deal
and you're sitting in front of a computer,
it might not be so important for you.
I will say that if your
vision is chronically bad
and you're squinting and you're straining,
that can cause headaches,
irritation of your eyes,
all sorts of issues.
So I do recommend you go
get your eyes checked.
That's part of being a healthy person.
Panic! At The LSDisco (laughing)
"Sometimes I get random
sharp pains from my uterus
"that don't always happen on my period
"and they can make me
double over, is this normal?
Interesting that you can exactly pinpoint
that it's happening in your uterus
as opposed to your ovaries,
your fallopian tube,
your stomach, your intestines.
If it's not happening along
with your menstrual cycle,
perhaps there's a good reason
for you to go see your doctor
and make sure that it's not something
going on with your
gastrointestinal system.
There could be many
different things happening.
And that's why I think you need a doctor
to sort of isolate other symptoms
that may be going on simultaneously.
Again, the best way that
doctors make a diagnosis
is through a careful
history asking you questions
about what's happening,
and what other symptoms are going on,
and two, doing a proper physical exam,
putting their hands on you,
checking certain aspects, pressing,
listening with the stethoscope.
The art of the physical exam is not lost.
Loretta Pleska, "Does gum
really stay in my system
"for seven years if I swallow it?"
I need to know.
I must know where did this
urban legend start from?
If somebody can tell me in the comments,
I'm gonna be so grateful for this.
If you swallow gum, accidentally,
your teacher called on
you, someone yelled,
it's gonna come out of you with poop,
generally in a day or two.
Do you know how I know
that gum doesn't stay
in your system for seven
years, and I can prove it?
Because I've done colonoscopies!
I've done capsule endoscopies on patients.
I've literally given them
a capsule with a camera,
goes through their digestive
system, guess what?
No gum, nothing hanging
out there for seven years.
Gum is just basically plastics,
sometimes it's like resin.
Your body can't digest that.
It can digest the sugars
and stuff around it,
but it can't digest the actual gum.
So it essentially just makes its way
through your digestive system.
Now it doesn't mean you
should just start swallowing
a ton of gum, because what can happen,
and I've seen case reports of this,
is if you swallow too much gum,
it can form a big ball and
then cause an obstruction.
Or, if you swallow gum,
and then some kind of
weird substances around it
like a coin, batteries,
these case reports happen with children,
the gum can encapsulate the
coin or the battery or whatever
and then cause a blockage as well.
But if you just swallow gum occasionally
it's gonna come out in your
poop, not the end of the world.
Don't worry about it.
Keira's Cloud, "How bad is it
"to inhale helium from a balloon?"
All I'll say is, it's not ideal.
The only thing you should
be breathing in is air.
Notice I didn't say oxygen.
'Cause if you breathe in 100% oxygen,
kinda doesn't make sense,
'cause atmospheric oxygen is around 20%.
See how I knew that?
I went to school, I remember some facts.
I don't know why I thought
that was fun to say.
Marie Teresa, like Mother Teresa.
"Let's say you're educated
"on how to do CPR but not licensed."
"Somebody drops and needs CPR.
"No one there knows a
thing about how to do it.
"Is it best to help the person,
will you get in trouble?"
Good Samaritan Law should
protect you in this instance
because if the person's
heart truly did stop
and they need CPR and you don't do it
for the fear that you may do it wrong,
that person's already gone.
You need to do CPR!
We need to not be afraid to do CPR!
In fact, a recent study has come out
and shown that women get less CPR
when they have a cardiac
arrest, their heart stops,
in public, because people are
afraid to touch female chests.
We should not be afraid to do this.
If someone's heart stops,
meaning they have no pulse,
or they're not breathing
and they're unconscious, please do CPR
after calling for help
so that you could extend
their chance of survival.
We need to be doing CPR.
There's huge movements from
New York Presbyterian Hospital
to the American Heart Association
talking about hands only CPR,
about how effective it is.
We should all learn how to do it.
And being licensed should only apply
in a health care setting.
Has nothing to do with if someone drops
and goes into cardiac arrest immediately
in front of you at the mall.
Julia Kaiser, "Can
leaving glass in your foot
"cause long term harm?"
It's gonna cause long-term pain!
Glass is not supposed to be in your foot.
Is it gonna cause permanent harm?
Not usually unless you
have diabetic neuropathy
and you don't feel it, and
it's constantly causing
an open wound there and you
can get an infection that way.
It's probably not the end of the world,
but if you see it, if
it's causing you pain,
it needs to be addressed.
You don't want to have an
open wound in your foot, why?
Because if you have an
open wound in your foot,
that's where bacteria might
come in and say what up?
When bacteria come in and say what up,
and you get an infection in your skin,
that's called cellulitis.
What's near your skin and your bone?
Ah, I gave it away.
What's near your skin? (laughing)
Bone!
If you get a bone infection
that's called osteomyelitis.
'Cause infection can spread from the skin
to the neighboring bone.
What happens then?
Ooh, IV antibiotics for a while.
That's problematic, your
foot's gonna hurt a lot.
Get that glass taken out.
(bell dinging)
Here's a playlist of my favorite
responding to comments videos.
I know you're gonna
love it, so click that.
Don't forget if you have questions,
leave 'em down below so I can answer them.
In fact, I'm gonna go
look at them right now.
You're gonna be in this
playlist though, right?
(hip hop music)